hi I'm gonna be your friend I'm gonna be
your friend x-ray who's x-ray [ __ ]
shooting me when I say hi November I
want to be your friend okay who's that
over there I want to be your friend Lima
Lima Lima oh yes I get five feet away
from you and then I can
it's much harder to throw a knife than
it is to shoot somebody to face
excellent shots a terrible throws in
shots I will be on your team forever all
right I have begun so I have the power
it help you if you have the gun no one
can help you oh you made that way too
easy you shut your mouth everyone kill
wait I don't care what he is
collision he deserves to die Alfa chuka
- now - now why aren't you shooting him
you [ __ ] can go play by yourself no
we're all in here what's happening I
assume that would kill one person and
play I will allow anyone they want to
come kill me walk into that mousetrap
yeah yeah it is yourself oh we're all
here would you do that come here I'm out
here
no matter I'll come find you again later
I didn't know you shot Oh who's that
with the gun I'm on your team me yeah
I'll stay right in front of you whatever
I'm looking at x-ray okay hear it if
he's the murderer he'll kill me no not
right now his cover's blown
come here yeah come here yeah wait yeah
actually
Oh someone's coming up wayde's down
there - wait wait try Oh guys you murder
x-ray hey where'd you go it's up there
on the box all right x-ray I kill me
okay kill me kill me kill me the
murderer I believe you wait come up and
get me wait here no one can hurt me ever
again
one good knife-throwing you're screwed
nah well yeah I go like that and then no
knife throw okay are you nowhere and
everywhere what's going on over there my
knife come back knife a zombie can't you
make that shot I was jumping around and
stuff he's good oh crap
I think maybe I was misled and we're
supposed to kill the chicken